if I paint you can't buy a lot you can't
put a lawn fertilizer or grass seed or
whatever come on all statewide really
you know it's time for our seat to be
opened up we're tired of not being able
to buy the things that we need go to the
hairdresser's get out there done that
where I start to buy my Halloween stuff
what am I not my Halloween stuff so
funny that it's April oh my god ROH
these people [ __ ] wouldn't last dude
oh oh [ __ ] boohoo you couldn't go to
your [ __ ] favorite dive bar for 30
days get over it [ __ ] off man that's oh
man what sorry go ahead no that's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that really irks me when
people were like why are we staying
inside it's cuz the [ __ ] there's
limited [ __ ] medical staff you
[ __ ] if a doctor dies from this [ __ ]
you're not gonna [ __ ] step up and do
his job so shut the [ __ ] up stay inside
and watch your [ __ ] Netflix man yeah
but then but who's we can't get lawn
seed Oh [ __ ] and and what happened
light bulbs yeah how am I gonna change
the light bulb my hair looks like [ __ ]
ah it's just five dollars
[Laughter]
you